all right how about this for something
to talk about the morality of Shadow of
the Colossus Shadow of the Colossus was
originally released for the PlayStation
2 in 2005 and re-released in
high-definition for the PlayStation 3 in
2011 serving as a loose prequel to 2001
s echo the game places the player in
control of wander a young man who has
brought the body of a young woman named
mano to a temple in the far-off
forbidden lands to petition an entity
known as doorman to resurrect her
doorman agrees to launders request but
first tasks wander with destroying the
sixteen colossi that hold the doorman
captive and the rest of the game unfolds
from there as the player first locates
the various colossi figures out their
weakness and slays them dicks
Shadow of the Colossus has rightly
received praise for many for its
emotional complexity and moral nuance
now it's important to remember going
into this that as with all narratives
our interests are instinctively aligned
to those of the protagonist even when
those goals are bad or evil we are
emotionally predisposed to share the
protagonists desire to achieve those
goals so much of what we will focus on
are the counter implications to the
otherwise self-evident emotional value
of fulfilling launders quest wanders
goal is one that is entirely congruous
with typical fantasy video game
narratives essentially it's just a remix
of slaying the dragon and rescuing the
princess slay the colossi resurrect the
doomed girl but this quest is tinged
with uncertainty wanders superficially
virtuous goal leading him to do things
that are questionable the sixteen
guardians of dormant power are hulking
monsters of earth fur and masonry with a
design aesthetic evocative of
architecture a palette of materials and
shapes that makes them look like some
ancient forgotten Watchtower come to
life they are fearsome imposing and
often wrought on a scale that makes them
difficult to comprehend well wander must
mount or ride all of the colossi in
order to slay them by a
they're literally magical weakpoint most
still fit into something approaching a
human scale being the size of a large
animal or a small house but a few are so
large that they become terrain the game
presents the colossi in conflicting
emotional context of fear and empathy
the first of these context fear is the
easy one given their scale their alien
composition their seeming
indestructibility it is easy to frame
the colossi as opponents to present them
as adversaries to be vested in a contest
of skill to show them as a hostile
opposition to your protagonists entered
righteousness they are large they wield
weapons of massive proportions their
silhouettes are frightening and jagged
and many of them are outright deadly
however with each one the designers have
carefully crafted a story that begins
here with fear and intimidation and
progresses towards empathy and sadness
more often than not this is a story told
literally from bottom to top as the most
common pattern for engaging with the
various colossi is to approach from the
ground find a way to climb onto the
Colossus and then work your way to the
head for the killing blow the story of
each Colossus then is told from the feet
to the face
armored hooves stone spikes and wrought
iron give way to leathery skin and fur
that although just a digital simulacra
one can't help but imagine as bristle
Ian's not altogether unpleasant like a
camel or a bear from there the player
directs wander to the head where the
camera swings around to frame wander
along with a colossus face the eyes
which look small beady and mildly
sinister from the ground here look
plaintive curious almost playful up
close many of the colossi have faces
that are more than a little silly and
childlike a favorite of mine being the
monkey like a Gaius
from the ground Gaius is of menacing
sting and unstable night on ball feet
that tries to crush you with its massive
stone sword until you climb to its round
silly face and are expected to plunge
your own
sword in to attack the game however
doesn't rub this in there is no grand
moment of pathos a single peer in the
range shot there is only your own
self-doubt in the correctness of
Dorman's quest your own sense of right
and wrong debating if it's the right
choice to destroy something as majestic
as avión part of how the game sells this
complexity is by not simply playing the
same notes over and over this is to keep
the gameplay feeling fresh keeping the
puzzles from getting too repetitive and
formulaic but it also serves to
effectively muddy the moral waters some
of the colossi are simply horrifying in
their design unlovable bodies of menace
and blades The Tortoise Vacheron is a
literal ball of spikes and is highly
aggressive seeding laundry with its
projectile attacks Vacheron is as barren
and unlovable as the blasted wasteland
it lives in the sky serpent phalanx is
impressive daunting but also utterly
alien the water bound Pelagia has a
crown of teeth ringing its head the
three smallest colossi are also three of
the most aggressive and deadly two of
them celosia and shinobi a call on
primal fears their design devoting a
pastiche of lions and wolves ancient
human predators however even then there
are moments of humanity injected celosia
fears of the fire and recoils when
wander wields a torch in its face
driving it backwards until it falls from
a cliff shattering its armor and
revealing its weak spots
similarly the fight against the
terrifying skeletal horse Phaedra is
punctuated by a moment where wander must
stab Phaedra in the back of the neck to
make it seize up in pain so he can
deliver the killing blow to its head all
of these storytelling mechanisms are
brought to a climax in the ultimate
fight against the 16th colossus malice
setting the stage for the encounter
wander must travel to the far south
leaping across the rickety bridge on the
back of his horse aggro the bridge
collapses wander is thrown from a grows
back and a grove plummets into the
ravine deprived of his last living
companion wander must ascend to the top
of the plateau to face his final
challenge
MELAS is enormous towering over the
southern plateau malice is the tallest
of the colossi by almost double it is
also the deadliest of them all firing
bolts of energy that home in on wander
and sent him skittering across the
ground the arena in which you engage
malice is a battlefield littered with
barricades and trenches almost as though
whatever ancient people built malice
found themselves laid siege by their own
creation until they were able to bolt
the Colossus feet to the ground leaving
it abandoned and stationary at the edge
of the world
approaching malice feels like stepping
into Armageddon a rain-soaked plateau
still scarred from some ancient battle
however even through all that as wander
nears the end of the puzzle he has
brought face to face with the final
Colossus where he is inspected like an
oddity malthus's I switched from the
aggressive orange high alert state to
the passive teal even this the final
moments there is pause the approach to
the final sigil could just as easily
have been framed and executed as it so
often is in the God of War series
another set of games from the same era
concerned with the main character
crawling on gigantic opponents in order
to slay them but no this was not a
technological limitation the game is
already full of so many impressive
moments of transitions at this pause
where wander stands and is inspected by
the being he will soon kill is a
conscious decision they had the power to
do almost anything they imagined and
they chose this wander is tasked by
doorman with slaying sixteen beings
none of which truly bear any ill will
towards wander even as he poses a threat
to their very existence beings who
aren't mere automaton but inhabit some
space in between construct and living
thing they are stone and metal animated
by magic but also flesh and fur and they
cry out in pain when wander plunges his
sword into them critical to building the
complexity of the games emotional
landscape is the composition of the end
of each Colossus of life as wander
climbs each Colossus and music swells in
its heroic energy the kind of blood
pumping soundtrack you would
back to a company great piece but with
that final blow the music turns fast
grievin
wander has his moments of heroic victory
as the Colossus crumbles around him
before the black tendrils of dormant
power escape and surge into his body
leaving him unconscious on the ground
the answer for morph ization of the
colossi the injection of human qualities
to evoke empathy is played out in
Reverse on wander with each Colossus he
destroys his physical form degrades his
humanity withering away until he is left
a husk to be possessed by doorman it is
not built to guilt the player but it is
still made to feel tragic the game makes
no commentary on choice however because
at the end of the day while Shadow of
the Colossus is a participatory
experience it is not about that
participation Shadow of the Colossus is
definitively wanders story even though
the game world is open with almost the
entire area accessible from the very
start the player is not given the
opportunity to alter wanders ultimate
path nor is the player impelled with the
notion that they can make a different
choice perhaps even the right choice by
turning off the game or putting the
controller down the players
participation is not in complicity but
in reenactment the story projected is
amiss the game as retelling the player
ultimately inhabits the role of wander
in the same way an actor becomes Macbeth
without assuming the guilt for Duncan's
murder like a performer the player
experiences the game simultaneously as
participant and observer aware of the
external context of the story even as
their participation makes it real the
brilliance of Shadow of the Colossus is
emotional landscape doesn't truly come
together until after the final showdown
throughout wanders journey he is pursued
by the shaman Iman and his entourage of
soldiers who finally arrive in the
Forbidden Land just in time to witness
malice idol in the temple shattering
with malice death there is a standoff
between wandering iman that results in
wanders body being fully possessed by
doorman though only the masculine
component of Dorman's voice remains iman
flees casting a powerful binding spell
that traps doormen long enough for Iman
and his surviving soldiers to escape
collapsing the bridge out of the
Forbidden Land behind
the doorman recedes leaving wander his
body broken and frail to resist the
spells pull but in the end it is
irresistible and he is pulled into the
void when the dust has finally settled
mono the dead girl wakes up from the
altar as a wounded aggro limps into the
temple together they inspect the pool
where the doorman possessed wander was
entombed and find an infant boy with
curious horns growing from his head
asked shadowing the titular main
character of the team's previous game
eco the three of them silently wind
their way to gather up the temple to a
hidden garden doorman in all their
ferocity and animosity towards the
shaman through their manipulation of
wander to their own ends is still a god
of life doorman is caged because doorman
is troublesome doorman complicates the
hierarchy very little of their character
is actually demonstrated and what is
demonstrated always exists in duality as
shadows gather around wander doves
gather around mono what we are told of
doorman comes almost entirely from a
proven adversary Lord Iman a man who was
himself willing to ritually sacrificed
mono for unknown ends wanders actions
are tragic lamentable even but the
consequences of those actions are not
nearly so clear-cut the final moments
with mono in the garden are framed as
peaceful serene a moments of hope and
reverse what comes after that the
threads that connect Shadow of the
Colossus to eco are left largely to
implication in innuendo mythical gaps to
be filled by speculation but the one
thing that is clear is that this is not
the end Dorman's release does not
trigger Armageddon by the time of eco
things appear to be in disrepair but
those events that world is separated
from oh no in the garden by hundreds
perhaps even thousands of years such is
moral complexity events with upsides and
downsides in both the present future and
far future the ultimate judgment of
wander is left to you the observer to
decide based on your own values
[Music]